نحن
دائما يعني سلاله واحده
تتجدد حتى لو يعني لم تختفي تماما لكن نحن
امتدادا لهن
ممكن لما يعني انا لم اشترك الحقبه لكن
بالحديث مع دائما مع والدتي مع والدي ان
الحياه كانت بهذيك الفتره كانت بسيطه اكثر
فالناس كانوا بسطاء جدا كانوا على سجيتهم
شفافين اكثر
كفنان يهتم بهذا الشيء يعني يحسه كثيرا
والعلاقه مع الحاضر من خلال هذه الصور هل
تجد بان هناك علاقه بالفعل بين هذه
اللوحات هناك علاقه قويه
يعني المراه انا لما رسمتها تجسدت التراث
والموروث
الهويه
الهويه حاضره في كل جمال ومكان
ولا يوجد هناك
مجتمع بدون هويه ما شاء الله احنا هويتنا
قويه واصيله يجب ان نعتز ونفتخر بها
المراه لها حضور كبير في اعمالك وزي ما
قلنا المراه في المروث الشعبي المراه ربه
البيت
المراه الريفيه المزارعه من تضع السلال
على راسها
وايضا هناك المراه المنطلقه المراه
المتحرره المراه غير المعنيه يمكن المراه
الموسيقيه وفي غيرها كمان كيف نفهم هذا
هذا الترابط يعني بين بين الشكلين
النموذجين للمراه
انه
هويه الانسان تتجدد
[موسيقى]
ويجب احنا نركز على الجانب الجيد منها
فمع مرور الزمن مع مرور الوقت تتغير
تتداخل تتاثر بما حولها
هويتنا اثرت بعد العولمه بالجانب
بالغرب لكن مازلنا محافظين على هويتنا
لذلك ترى المراه بهويتها في اعمالي بهويه
وموروثها السعودي والمراه المنطلقه
في وقت الراهن